[Music]
hey guys as you can tell by the title
itself in this film ring in the
seemingly legit licked outline for the
final episode of the final season before
I get right into it let me explain to
you how this leaked outline does seem to
be legit way back in August of last year
see the email of a fan claiming that
here's the outline of the each episode
of the final season upon reading it I
thought it was quite on point but main
reason I did not share before is due to
fact that at that particular time there
have been numerous fake outlines
circulating the internet so I thought
this was just yet another fake one
here's why this outline that was sent to
me might be the actual outline of the
final season as already said and as you
can see by yourself I received this
outlined way back in August of last year
that's a couple of months before Game of
Thrones started filming its final season
that's a couple of months before any
leaked photo was taken and yet its
outline matches perfectly with totally
eccentric photos that followed I've
already shared outlines for the first
five episodes of the final season so if
you haven't seen them yet make sure to
do so and then come back to watch this
video
that way you're caught up with
everything that has already happened in
this film bringing in the outline of the
final episode of the Game of Thrones
series before I start let me warn you
once again that this leaked outline does
seem to be legit so if you don't want
anything to be potentially spoiled it's
time for you to close this video ok the
outline claims that the episode opens up
with a shot of census corpse hanging
from the walls of King's Landing
the battle for in laning rages says the
night King continues bring down much of
the capital I get a stop right there to
say that this opening shot of the final
episode will surely leave huge amount of
us in shock but it's safe to say that
the show decided to include this scene
so we would be reminded that Queen
Cersei is evil and has to be killed sir
securing sensor has been foreshadowed
multiple times and they provided all the
hints and clothes in previous video when
she gets killed however since his corpse
being hanging from the walls means
landing might have been for share of
this Val
back in season 7 episode 3 Jamie
revealed to Elena what ideas search the
hair regarding her death and one
included Elena being killed and hanged
from the walls of King's Landing how
will it happen sure she had several
ideas putting you through the streets
and beheading you in front of the red
keep playing your life and hanging you
from the walls of King's Landing it's a
battle for the capital rages as the neck
tingled thing is bringing down much of
the capital with his undead dragon in
the previous episode the night King
started burning down King's Landing
including King's Landing Don which by
the way has been confirmed by many
leaked folks back to the outline it says
that bran is having
so past and future events the first
vision includes Danny walking through
the ruins of the red keep entering the
Great Hall and Cindy aren't run covered
by snow
the next vision includes Brandon and
Ricker start being executed by the Mad
King we didn't see a vision of daily
walking through a fire followed by a
vision in which Jon's hand is being
burned Moran's vision already played a
huge role in the first five episodes of
the final season and it only makes sense
for his visions to keep playing its role
until the bitter end we can only hope
that brain will be a bit better at
reading them so far brans visions helped
us realize that ginjuries hurts his son
it helped the living side locate the
night king it shocked brain that
Winterfell would be burned down which
they did in a huge battle against the
army of the Dead it even might have
revealed us that Kings intentions and
motivations which we will learn in
Episode four and invite have to guess
will learn away through brain and his
visions as much as brans visions have
been useful for the living side and as
much as it gave us the fans goals and
hints regarding the upcoming events it
can also backfire in the links I put it
badly the visions are interpreted wrong
the best example would be a vision in
which branch sovereign d'Alene stars in
the gun companies selling north which
accompanied with information of Circe's
any help made bran conclude that us
coming to the north say it while he
could actually come to kill all of them
it resulted with Jon being captured and
escorted to Cersei make no mistake these
visions must certainly hold some huge
claws regarding a great war and its ends
so if you'd like take a moment to think
about these visions and you might figure
out what it foreshadows the one in which
brain sees Brandon Erica start being
executed by the Mad King has actually
already been filmed and was meant to be
used as a flashback in season one but it
never aired so the possibility of it
appearing now is very high anyways back
to the outline it states that Jaime the
Hound entered the red keep dungeons they
kill a few guards and said Jon Snow free
Jamie tells John to go out and help his
people John picks his sword Longclaw
Jamie gives John a villain still dagger
and says go Prince help your people win
this war Jimi's died in episode 5 Alper
technically Stark and as I said in the
end of the last video Jaime has
certainly not been resurrected or
anything like that
the Jaime we see at the end of episode 5
is not Jaime it's our star crank James
face and her own sword needle
additionally it's measured that the
Hound wields widow's wail Jaime's
Valyrian steel sword meaning that upon
Jaime's death he picked up his sword and
is now heading Victoria to put an end to
serfs in his brother's Mountain
this is Arya wearing Jamie's face and
building her own sword finding her way
into the red keep as she announced she
would they said John free and Jaime who
is actually Arya gives him her Valyrian
steel dagger
but antaria take of jim's face and sage
on that it's her well that's because
john would not let her go and try to
kill the met queen in her own home
well of course it's also because of the
intensity of a scene as most offense
still will not realize it's Arya Stark
and not Jamie Durie scenario first to
join as a princess because at the end of
the third episode after John was
captured Sam told the azor Ahai prophecy
embraer will to everyone Joshua lineage
which led living to proclaim John the
prince that was promised to hear that is
prophesied to save them all from the
long night anyways the next scene is at
Dragonstone then commence maester wolkan
same Jeremy send it to take care of her
Finn's she says if I don't come back
take care of my twins as she prepares to
depart for King's Landing
semmen maester wolkan insists that she
should rest as her childbirth has been
complicated and her health has not fully
recovered yet Joris Aeschylus your
children need you on which Daniel
responds with if I stay here Jorgen
stays here too the war would be lost all
of us will die including my children I
have to go and help my people win this
war Joran's is that she must bring him
with her as well since his experienced
leader and warrior Anvil's heart's pain
Daniel loves Jorah to accompany her then
he flies dragon to the capital the final
episode of Game of Thrones without Danny
and Dragon facing the night king Indian
that dragon bazarian would not be the
epic finale we've all been expecting one
can only hope that Dana's health has
recovered enough for her to use dragon
as best she can since back in the last
episode she could not even sit but that
was before mr. Vulcan Sam helped her in
childbirth that resulted at the twins
and everyone's survival or at least thus
far the autumn continues by stating that
the next shot is in the red clip the
Great Hall we see Surtsey on the Iron
Throne
the mountain stands just beside her the
rest of the Queen's Guard is a bit
further
Qyburn and the Pyromancer have a meeting
with the Queen Cersei says the time has
come initiate wildfire attack across the
city most of the Queen's Guard is in
shock the Pyromancer knots
Qyburn s-sorry sir no grace I am do as
commanded
sirs response khyber nuts the Pyromancer
in Qyburn exit the throne room as
they're leaving we hear Cersei laughing
we also hear sword slash Jaime enters
the Great Hall Circe is in shock and
says Jaime I've heard you died
protecting the start but well I suppose
it does matter
you'll still die one way or another what
are you doing here the count full of
Jaime and enters the Great Hall as well
cleaning his bloody sword with asleep
sir stood the notices Jaime the counts
body swords Cersei realizes that they
have killed Pyromancer and Qyburn Jimmy
doesn't say a word he smiles Clegane
brothers are having an eye contact
kill them kill them started commenced
means guard six members of the Queen's
Guard attack Jamie the Hound helps Jamie
kill two members of the Queen's Guard
before he starts fighting his brother
the mountain Jamie kills the remaining
four Knights the hound kills the
mountain but is gravely wounded in the
process
Jamie approaches Cersei raises his hand
to his face the shot goes behind the arm
crown and when we see Jamie again he's
no longer Jamie it's Arya Stark Circe is
in shock Cersei stands up walks a few
steps down the iron throne and says no
no you will all burn and laughs you will
all burn you will all die starts and
continues laughs intensifies search it
and turns her back Torian starts walking
back to the arm drone the shot focuses
on serves his face the blood starts
coming out of Circe's mouth Aria steps
in the back Cersei makes one more step
towards the throne button collapses
Cersei reaches her hand towards the arm
Poenari gets away this starts and
Targaryen send her regards sorry says
and slits his throat I did not want to
interrupt this part of the outline
because it's just beautiful mrs. Cersei
who has now become the met queen by all
means the hound and Arya save the city
and it's 1 million people by stopping
the Pyromancer and Qyburn to initiate
wildfire attack within witness an epic
fight and much of a little gamble Arya
takes out most of the Queen's Guard
single-handedly while center finally has
revenge or his brother the mountain
let's hope his wounds are not that
serious and he actually survives and
then the best part Arya Stark takes of
Jaime's facing avenge is her sister
family or a step search in the back and
then slits her throat the same way Jaime
killed the Mad King but before she does
so she says the Starks and Targaryen
send their regards
absolutely beautiful that's what I have
to say about this part of the outline
the showrunners could not do it any
better in my opinion ok back to the
outline it says that we see a bird's-eye
shot of huge battle for King's Landing
the army the dead fights the living on
the streets of the capital the living
seem to be scattered without the true
leader to lead them the small amount of
the golden company that survived the
fall of the King's Landing walls
retreats Tyrion tries to rally the
Lannister soldiers but without much
success as most of them are scattered
fighting the whites across the whole
city
Germania tracking the northerners are
scattered as well and Natalya has most
of the tally free army rallied but they
suffer huge casualties as the whites
keep devastating their formations Theon
manages to rally his Ironborn forces
directing them to use fire arrows
against White's grave arm is the only
commander who has his forces under
control young solid fighting a large
unit valance formations with a dragon
lasted Spears
this huge battle has been confirmed as
well with reports of 600 extras from a
huge battle sequence at King's Landing
set
anyways the Outlander and states that
Johnston then finally joins the battle
for King's Landing he starts fighting
the army of the Dead or a stark joins
the battle as well
Tyrion ginjury grave or mantheon see
John and start commanding their men to
rally to John Theon shouts to the king -
the king
Johnston rallies most of the living side
and leads them into the fight John
charges first with ginjury Arya Brienne
and bran and Theon following closely
Tyrion commands men to start firing fire
balls using trebuchets on the army of
the Dead this part has also been
confirmed by many leaked photos from
season 8 set in which we can see
trebuchets we also have a video from the
King's Landing set in which the
trebuchet is being tested ok guys this
would be the first half of the final
episode the other half is shown in
process and will be published as soon as
possible the first part including many
major events such as are in the Hound
saving the entire living side from
wildfire sources death the cool game
ball and a huge battle between the
living and the dead that still rages
however the second part is by far more
intense and shocking without getting
much away let me just say that we'll see
a huge fights between the living and the
dead between the dragons and between Jon
Snow and the 19 who will win the great
for who will die who will sit on the
Iron Throne
it's all there most of the other half
has also been confirmed by many season 8
filming leaks and as always I hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace
[Music]
[Music]